- [Narrator] This Sweetgreen
salad starts at 14.95.
Add avocado and it goes to 16.95.
But even as it's sold millions
of these bowls to customers,
Sweetgreen has been losing
millions of dollars a month.
With over 200 locations,
Sweetgreen is a fast casual restaurant
trying to broaden the fast food market
to include salads made
with fresh ingredients.
But building the infrastructure
and logistics to accomplish
this goal hasn't come cheap.
- We're not that fancy yet.
- They've always sort
of branded themselves
as a tech company,
and so they talked a lot about
changing the food system.
At one point they said that they wanted
to be the McDonald's of better eating.
Now they've had to translate
some of those lofty
ambitions into reality,
and that's challenging.
- [Narrator] This is The
Economics of Sweetgreen.
Sweetgreen brought in hundreds of millions
in investment before going
public in November 2021.
In an SEC filing, it reported having
about 1.35 million active customers.
After its IPO, its stock surged
to bring the company's
value to over $6 billion.
- I'm obsessed.
- [Narrator] But its
market cap has since fallen
to almost one quarter of that.
While individual Sweetgreen
locations are profitable,
the company has struggled to
overcome high overhead costs.
In its last quarterly report,
the company announced net losses
of more than $27 million.
- Hi, what can I get
started for you to eat?
- [Narrator] The company's
costs begin with its salads.
- There's a few things that
drive the cost of what we do.
We buy really, really high quality food
from farmers we know and trust.
- [Narrator] Most
restaurants source their food
through distributors,
which give them access
to a wide range of food at low prices.
And on top of that,
these distributors handle
the transportation logistics.
Sweetgreen, on the other hand,
works directly with farms.
Another major cost is labor.
Sweetgreen has staff assemble meals
and also do a significant
amount of food prep.
- Most restaurants process
their food centrally
and ship it out around the country.
In order to maximize the
taste and the freshness,
we believe food should be made closer
to where the guests are eating the food.
So we actually make our food
every day in our fresh prep kitchen.
- [Narrator] Beyond
restaurant level expenses,
Sweetgreen has also put a
lot of money into technology.
- We've built out from just
having a pickup channel,
to building our own native delivery,
partnering with some marketplaces,
and even building catering
and our outpost business.
We've also been able to integrate
machine learning and AI
in order to personalize
a lot of the recommendations
that we give you,
as well as things like
our loyalty program.
- Sweetgreen hasn't just
built tech for customers,
it's also built apps for employees
to plan out how much food to make
at different times of day,
so food is fresh but ready
when they expect customers.
- I would say that the founders
are trying to be more disciplined now.
They've also earned a lot
in stock compensation,
and I think there is certain amount
of tech alignment thinking there.
But you know, they are
coming down to earth a bit
and trying to trim expenses
where they can and try
to become more efficient.
But again, it's gonna take time.
- [Narrator] The question
is how to do that
without changing the parts
of the business that customers care about.
- Our path to profitability
in a net income basis
comes from a few levers.
The first is continuing
to grow our footprint.
This year, we're opening
about 35 new restaurants.
Second is growing sales in existing stores
where a huge portion of that increase
goes to lifting the profitability
of those restaurants.
The third is being very disciplined
on our cost structure to make sure
that the incremental profit we're making
is flowing through the bottom line.
- [Narrator] Sweetgreen
has closed some restaurants
in cities like Boston and New York.
It's also had some layoffs.
- One of the challenges
for the business has
clearly been the pandemic
and the recovery from the pandemic.
- [Narrator] In 2019, Sweetgreen stores
were concentrated in urban centers,
but recently it's been focused
on expanding outside cities.
- I think we're going to continue
to build out in the markets
that we currently operate in,
and looking to open up
one or two new markets a year
for the next several years.
- [Narrator] Sweetgreen recently hired
two former Chipotle executives
to help make its menu appeal
to a wider range of customers,
especially as it expands
past major cities.
That's important because
its path to profitability
centers on having enough
profitable restaurants to offset overhead.
To make each restaurant more profitable,
it's also counting on increasing loyalty
and leveraging technology.
Sweetgreen has experimented
with loyalty programs for years,
and its most recent effort
is something called Sweetpass.
There are a few tiers in the program.
In the paid version of Sweetpass,
customers pay $10 per month
to get $3 off one salad per day.
So a customer would have to spend
at least $40 on salads per
month to come out ahead.
- In general, restaurants
are really pushing
these loyalty programs
because it makes a lot of sense
to try to get someone hooked.
You know, it's harder to advertise
to a new customer than it is to try
to just keep current one coming.
But you know, if you're going to eat that
every day for lunch, that is gonna add up.
- [Narrator] Sweetgreen hasn't shared
how many people have signed up
for its loyalty program, which
it still considers a pilot.
Another key strategy moving
forward is automation.
In 2021, Sweetgreen bought Spyce Food Co,
a startup that makes
automated food assembly lines.
And earlier this year,
it opened its first
so-called Infinite Kitchen
in Naperville, Illinois,
where salads are assembled robotically.
That enabled it to hire
one third fewer staff
without sacrificing efficiency.
Sweetgreen plans to continue
rolling this out to new locations,
and hopes to retrofit an
existing location in late 2024.
- Probably the biggest improvement
for our customers is
much faster throughput.
Typically, you can order your salad
and have it ready in under three minutes,
even in a very busy store.
- We believe what this will allow us to do
is provide a superior economic model.
This will significantly impact
and improve our unit economics,
which will allow us to continue
to scale in a profitable way,
and over time may even
give us some pricing power
as we think about creating healthy food
that is truly accessible for everyone.
- [Narrator] Sweetgreen
has made some progress
towards profitability.
Last quarter, the company announced
it was profitable for the first time,
though this comes with
some qualifications.
Sweetgreen is only profitable
based on a measure called EBITDA,
which excludes a variety
of costs such as taxes, acquisition costs,
restructuring costs, and
stock-based compensation.
It's a measure that's
popular with tech companies,
but doesn't follow generally
accepted accounting principles.
- It's a pretty heavy list of things
that aren't included, but by doing this,
I mean, they can say that
they just had their
first profitable quarter,
which is in Q2, and they wanna show
some progress to investors.
And I think that does show
a certain magnitude of progress,
but it's not all the way there.
- [Narrator] The company
though is confident
that it can become a national business
based on three things.
It creates a new category in the market,
has capital to expand,
and maintains a loyal customer base.
- We see Sweetgreen as having all three
of those ingredients as we move forward.
- You know, I think there will continue
to be challenges as we scale,
whether it be how we
scale our supply chain,
how we scale our technology,
how we scale our leadership.
But I think the big thing is proving
that this type of offering
can work all around the country.
- I think they're pretty honest
that they're trying to become
a more mature business now.
And you know, for a young company
founded by young founders,
that makes sense that
that's a little bumpy.
(gentle upbeat music)